okay welcome to customizing Jupiter lab
using extensions I'm Alex Bozarth I'm a
software engineer at IBM Center for open
source and data and AI technologies also
known as kadai just as a starting point
I'm making this talk an open Q&A so if
you guys have questions at any time just
raise the hand and I'll pause the talk
the entire second half this talk is
going to be one long demo so those
questions are important
I'll also be stepping away from the mic
to cough every once in a while so pardon
that so to start off a little bit about
me I've been a software developer at IBM
for four years now a little bit over
four years now over those years I've
also become a ppm C for Apache Livi
which is an incubating project with
Apache part related to patchy spark and
I've given open source contributions to
Apache spark Apache livvie
the IBM model asset exchange the IBM
model data exchange and most recently
Jupiter lab which is topic here I'm
currently working on creating AI centric
Jupiter lab extensions trying to help
out the data scientists that you want to
use Jupiter lab given him more
extensions to work with to give them a
better environment I also put my contact
information up there if anybody wants to
follow up after this these slides will
be available in some way yeah so that's
my email my twitter handle and my github
and my linkedin so that's me
short summary you know a quick summary
about today the Center for open source
data and AI technologies just a quick
spiel today aims to be to make AI
solutions dramatically easier to create
deploy and manage in the enterprise we
are an open source shop within IBM
pretty much fully dedicated to do an
open source development that will both
aid IBM and of course the open source
community that IBM wants to support
we're based in San Francisco and that's
a nice picture of our lobby it's real
plants so so yeah that's code a and I
got this cool image from my teammate
about IBM's open source participation
throughout the year IBM is active in the
open source community as both consumer
and a contributor and has been for
decades as you can see from all the
things that various parts of IBM has
been a part of
we might be big and old but we're not
not hip we are the big old fogies of the
industry but we are keeping in touch so
that's yeah that's just a little bit of
an introduction so with this talk I want
to kind of give you guys just some quick
questions like what is Jupiter lab what
are jupiter lab extensions why you
should use Jupiter lab extensions when
you should create Jupiter lab extensions
and in order to answer those questions
I'm gonna kind of go over starting up
Jupiter lab installing some basic
extensions and a demo of how you can
very quickly create a very simple
extension of your own and as I said
before open Q&A throughout this talk so
if anybody has a question interrupt me
just raise a hand so quick question to
start how many people here know what
Jupiter lab is how many people don't
know what Jupiter lab is okay so most
people generally know what Jupiter lab
is how many people have used Jupiter lab
okay so it's essentially the same group
so this will be pretty easy for the most
room jupiter lab is the next generation
UI for project jupiter yeah have a
little picture up there of it nice
simple it gives a web-based interface
for interacting not with Jupiter just
Jupiter notebooks but also other types
of text files terminals and using
extensions many many other types of
files and the goal is to eventually
replace the classic Jupiter notebook UI
you can get all of this off of their
front page pretty straightforward it is
next generation Jupiter notebooks any
questions
I like this audience so Jupiter
extensions what are they
Jupiter lab from the beginning was
designed to be extendable extensions of
Jupiter lab allow you to create new file
editors for different types of files and
output your visualization in different
ways so you can show a JSON file both in
an editor or in an interactive drop-down
environment it allows you to add buttons
and menu items to other people's
extensions and art and features that
already exist in Jupiter lab and one of
the coolest things is you can actually
create back-end api's that run in
Jupiter lab that other jupiter lab
extensions can then call so if you want
to create a new API and another
extension that uses it you can do both
and Jupiter lab itself is actually just
a giant bundle of extensions they built
it so everything you see in Jupiter lab
is just an extension that just comes as
the core jupiter lab people kind of
getting along
getting that cool so why should we be
using jupiter lab extensions well one
the core extensions are intentionally
limited in scope they don't want a data
scientist and an engineer to necessarily
be getting each other's super specific
extensions when they open up Jupiter lab
they want it to open up run very quickly
and have the gist the basics
nothing extra so then you can customize
your own environment by installing
extensions you need because everybody
has different roles data science can use
it engineers can use it the layman can
use it so the idea is everybody has
their own scenario and you want to
install extensions to your scenario any
questions on the kind of the overview of
extensions
so I'm already into my demo so my goal
with this demo is I'm just gonna quickly
walk you through how to install an
extension in Jupiter lab that already
exists and then my step after that will
actually be to show you how to create
your own extension so I'm gonna just
quickly swipe over please say it works
yes okay so this is my terminal the best
part about this
you just type so I've already installed
Jupiter lab that's pretty easy you just
hit installed Jupiter lab but I didn't
feel like having you guys wait while
it's installing so typing out Jupiter
lab I'm gonna increase the font size
here I don't usually do this okay it's
the same as every other app is that
easier to see okay
Jupiter lab it's really cool about this
is it will immediately open up Jupiter
lab in your default browser so this is
Jupiter lab as you guys said most you
guys have seen Jupiter lab before
correct so you in Jupiter lab you can
open up a notebook file you can open up
a Python file and you can see it's fully
editable in the Python file similarly
with the decor functional you can open
up a markdown and you can actually show
a markdown preview all of this is
included in core no extension required
but extensions are pretty easy to
install you can install them via command
line but there's actually an
experimental feature called the
extension manager you just turn it on it
gives me a giant warning in beta you
just turn it on and for those that
didn't notice there's a new little side
button over here extension manager I
have no extensions installed can
everybody see this size-wize cool so -
let's try to install extension so table
of contents is a great extension a lot
of people have talked about putting it
in core because it's such a common
extension so let's see TOC table
contents there it is it even has a
little install button if you click this
it will open up in a new tab the git
repo it's coming from
but we're just gonna click install you
can see the little blue bar go and it's
installing wait a sec and then it's done
and just asked us to rebuild real quick
so in the background while using Jupiter
lab it will rebuild extensions for you
dynamically without you having to go
close Jupiter lab and then once it's
finished rebuilding it will prompt us to
just refresh the page of course it is
building does take a second or two but
table of contents is a pretty small
extension doesn't take that long to
build and if you want to see oh it's
already done click reload and on reload
you will see there's a new tab over here
called for table of contents and it'll
show you the table of contents of
whichever notebook or even markdown file
if you click you see it goes to that tab
that's an easy basic extension probably
want to use you can all see how easy it
is to install and pre-done extension
that makes sense to everybody cool so
let's try some stolen another extension
where are you extensions there you are
let's try get a lot of people like using
get the jupiter lab team has a jupiter
lab kit extension which they would like
to remind people is not production ready
as they reminded me this week when i
mentioned that i was gonna use it in my
presentation so let's click install in
the get nope it gives us a weird warning
it says it needs a corresponding server
extension called jupiter lab - get well
sadly you can't install server
extensions through the UI like you can
install the front-end extensions so
we're gonna click cancel and we're gonna
install that one via the command line so
I have my little environment stuff saved
here
we are going to copy this so usually you
just do a pip install but because I'm
using Conda Conda doesn't like working
with native pip so I'm using a Content
stall from Conda Forge so you can see
the normal pip install is very easy so
we're gonna come over here I'm gonna
kill Jupiter lab just you had a nice
control see confirm and then I'm gonna
paste in my content style it's pretty
quick alright yes you can install them
the same way via command line yes yes
typically if you are a dev and you're
setting up an environment for all your
data scientists you would create a
script that would just go through and
install a bunch of them that's what my
team does for our data scientists so so
this is just a normal Condor or pip
install and it's done and then we just
have to rebuild Jupiter lab because I
don't feel like typing I'm just gonna
copy and paste Jupiter lab build if I
just started Jupiter lab it would have
then prompted me to build but I'm gonna
do this it takes a minute again because
all this is of course actually doing
these things this isn't all pre done all
I did was type out the commands to copy
and paste them so as you can see all
this is very quick this would take the
same amount of time for you guys
gotta love building
but again not super long everybody here
has had those 5 to 10-minute long builds
right forward longer
faster
so if you look at it says build minimize
so it's actually just building what's
changed and the dependent parts of it
when I am doing dev environment work I
typically do full cleans and complete
builds on every change just to make sure
I don't miss anything okay see nice and
quick compared to a lot of stuff I'm
just gonna do this so then let's run
Jupiter lock
I'm gonna kill this other tab okay it
remembered where we were and now inside
the extensions manager gets there we
also see that git has created a thing
it's also noticed that if I looked at my
file browser I'm not in a git repo so it
is telling me you're not in the git repo
and says go find a repo so if I had
switched to a folder with a repo it
would find it but I don't have that so
we're gonna do this I can get clone
right from in here and I am gonna get
ahead for our next demo and get clone
the repo we're going to use on in the
next part of the demo which is the
extension cookie cutter just copy that
URL in there and clone no it didn't like
it there was probably a space
let's see what did it not like
it really did not like that
yeah that's worked last night yeah it's
just the git clone in the URL it's not
liking it today let's see if I can get
it from the next no it's just the URL
so once a dot get
or not
Wow I didn't like that so apparently
it's not liking me today but typically
you can do that we are just gonna go do
that in the terminal then because we can
so and you'll notice when I come back
it's already seen it's there so when I
open this up and I covered it the get
how it really didn't like it remember
when I said it's in not production
writing example of not production
ratings so as I said it worked last
night and it's not working today perfect
example of not production rating so I'm
gonna go back to my slides real quick
because I bet you anything there was a
step that I skipped when building but
worst case is we just move on yeah we're
just gonna move on unless anybody has
any questions about installing you
notice that the extension did get
installed though it's a good point to
point out I did mention it earlier
there's two types of extensions in
Jupiter lab there's lab extensions which
are front-end so like the table of
contents in the UI side those ones can
dynamically be added while running lab
then there are server extensions which
are typically the backend they are the
API extensions that allow that back-end
your for us your front-end extensions
those have to be built and run before
starting Jupiter lab and they and yeah
so that is installing pre-done
extensions so moving on to the next demo
which is let's create our own extension
so the repo I checked out was called
cookie cutter it's a extension cookie
cutter in typescript that the Jupiter
lab community has already made it's
really easy to use you check it out
we're just gonna CD into the cookie
cutter
it's called extension there we go and
we're gonna follow the instructions in
the readme so if we go over to here we
can open up the cookie cutter readme
I'll see markdown preview can get a
little weird we're just gonna put that
there so these are the steps pip install
cookie cutter
so let's pip install cookie cutter done
and then we use the cookie cutter to
generate it's just cookie cutter and
then the cookie cutter repo name this
allows you to create your own customized
cookie cutters and still use their
scripts and it's gonna give me props
it's warning me that I've done this
before and so yes I want to delete my
previous thing author I'm Alex we're
gonna call this my button and it's about
my button excuse me and it's asking for
a repo that I'll eventually push this to
I'm just gonna copy and paste it called
it just in case I decide to push it and
it created a whole extension so we're
gonna come back overdue for lab where we
can actually edit all this we fresh this
and you'll see there's a my button in
there now part in my asthma and so we're
gonna open up the my button extension
all of this is now generated we have the
package.json with all our build we're
gonna close all these extra tabs that
we've had open let's open up the index
file this is all nice and generated and
right now if you run this extension all
it does is when it starts it logs my
button has been activated pretty
straightforward but we want it to do
more than this so I have a couple pre
done lines already so we're gonna drag
so a couple up here all the way up here
we have this button dot ts file that I
created beforehand it hasn't some button
code that I'll explain a bit we're gonna
copy this we're just gonna go back to
the my button all the way into source
and we're just gonna paste it
and now it's in that directory all
through Jupiter lab we're gonna close
that real quick and then in order to
import it I can just import it in
typescript using my import line and then
in order to use this button I have two
nice lines of code that we put in this
activate function here
of course copy and paste never gets the
indentation correct because why would it
okay so what we're doing here is we're
creating an instance of my button from
that class then we're adding the widget
the button widget to notebook files so
whenever somebody opens a notebook it
knows that my button widget is going to
be run with that notebook and this is
the button file so what I did is I
created an extension uses all of these
nice long models but this is essentially
saying that it's gonna be part of a
notebook file and I created a create new
function which takes in the notebook and
I create a button my buttons called my
button when you click it does a nice job
of script alert you did it and then I
can easily add my button to the notebook
toolbar I put it in position 9 right at
the end called my button and then it
returns the button itself so now when a
notebook starts up it runs this it
creates a new widget and they create in
creating the new widget I've given it
back a button to put on its toolbar as
you notice there's a lot imports up here
so we need to quickly copy and paste all
those imports into our package JSON
otherwise it will just not build
so open up the package.json you'll see
that JSON is open by default in a JSON
viewer which is pretty cool but not
super useful to us right now so we can
do open with and we can open in the
editor instead when we come down here to
dependencies and we just paste in all
these new dependencies make sure all my
commas are correct and then the key is
Jupiter lab by default doesn't autosave
so you need to save each of these files
to make sure they built right
okay so we've customized that it's a
pretty kind of following how easy that
is to kind of create your own thing in
general okay and then we are gonna open
up the readme for this newly created
application it has build instructions in
the readme that was generated by the
cookie cutter the build instructions are
run JL p.m. which is a wrapper around
yarn
I think it's yarn or is it then yeah
it's yarn and we're just gonna CD first
into my button and then we're just gonna
run JL p.m. and it's gonna build my
button and hopefully it will succeed on
first try as long as I saved everything
and there's no missing commas so because
of the fact that I did input a handful
of packages that were not there before
has to download all those packages from
MPM so it does take a minute on the
first bill
so on your very first build you run JL
p.m. and it also downloads all the
requirements from NPM but as you're
editing your widget you don't actually
have to do JL p.m. the whole time you
just have to do JL p.m. build which just
quickly rebuilds the code without
redownload in your requirements and
what's really cool as we come over here
we go over to our extension manager
Nothings there's right let's refresh
this see nothing's there
so we must have missed a step yeah we
did so the next step is Jupiter lab
extension link so we just in this
directory we're gonna link this current
directory to jupiter lab so Jupiter lab
knows that there's an extension in this
directory that it should be running you
can also link it and install in other
ways but the simplest is linking local
so we're just gonna quickly run that and
it's thinking thinking thinking thinking
so what it's actually doing in the
background is it's actually gonna do a
again a minimize rebuild of Jupiter lab
to make sure that Jupiter lab is gonna
run with this extension and okay and
again this is all able to be done while
Jupiter lab is running because it is a
front end extension but of course it
takes a minute or two because it's still
a build why it's building any questions
you would have to restart the whole
thing because back-end extensions are
stan cheated and runned at the initial
runtime because they are server-side so
they're usually written in Python
whereas front-end extensions are usually
written in typescript but not the not
always yeah
yes it's the it's the extension manager
it will I believe it only searches for
front-end so if as you saw with the get
if the front and extension relies on a
back-end extension it will warn you that
it won't work without it I believe it's
the I believe it's a pip I believe it's
a pip sir it's NPM tax and so you and
you can actually when you create your
own and publish your own on github you
can just add that or you when you
publish it on NPM you can just add that
get tat that tag and then it will show
up in the search so you'll see over here
that my button is now shown up after
doing a quick refresh without restarting
Jupiter lab you also noticed that it
doesn't have this pretty nice logo this
logo is for people for extensions
developed by project Jupiter yeah so
it's already there
so now we're gonna come over here and
we're gonna back out and reopen one of
these notebooks you can see it always
opens it in whichever section you're
currently in
so you notice oh it's not liking me
let's try that again
yeah my button it's right there on the
end and when I click it you did it
super easy to install and you can make
that button do whatever you want and if
you create a server extension to go with
it you can have it call an API that then
takes input from the user and submits it
to a back-end that does something and
return something or you can make it just
say good job so this is how easy it is
to create a front-end extension you can
do this all inside of Jupiter lab
without ever restarting Jupiter lab and
you can do all your development in
Jupiter lab which is really cool so that
is the end of my demo I did include a
bunch of useful links and a link to
download this PowerPoint file so I don't
know how we're gonna share that link yes
they would have to install the
extensions the extensions are related to
their instance of jupiter lab not the
notebook so the notebook is just a file
and duper lab is closer to i like to
compare it to an ide but that's not
exactly the best comparison so their
instance of jupiter lab would need to
install those those extensions now if
you're using a cloud-based jupiter lab
so somebody else is running jupiter lab
on their servers and you're just oh and
you're just call opening it through your
web browser you don't have to run Jupe
lab local and so you're both running off
the same instance of the jupiter labs
then they would also have the same
extensions but if you're running it
local then you they would need to
install all those extensions so as far
as i remember if you are running a cloud
environment and you are both interacting
with the same jupiter lab instance in
the cloud you will have the same
extensions both server and front-end and
so if you install one I believe in
theory they should have it too but it
also depends on who your provider is a
lot of providers silo it per user so you
don't have that
yes they're lots of different companies
are creating bundles of extensions that
say these are all the extensions that
you should have use this script to
install them and according to my
coworker they can use binder yes
yeah
yeah
yeah if I remember correctly the person
who spins up there's a setting you can
disable the extension manager the UI one
that I've been showing you guys which
would then make sure users can't install
extensions or you can or the essentially
typically though it is cool that you can
do this on your own if you spin up your
own instance the DevOps team that is
running in the instance of your jupiter
lab in the cloud will typically have a
set amount of control that they have and
amount they want to give their users and
that is usually up to them and it can
range depending on how much they want
it's very customizable I given I mostly
work in the open and front-end I have
not touched the DevOps side as much I
have a co-worker who sits behind me does
it but that's all secondhand knowledge
and for me personally yes
yeah so oh I didn't actually mention
this so I've been mostly writing my own
extensions which sadly I we have not
published and I cannot share with you
despite having them done for a while but
I included a link to this PI data Berlin
talk from this last summer there was a
great talk where they just literally
spent a whole talk going through 20
different extensions that are great in
common to use and I have a link at the
end it's called a tour of Jupiter lab
extensions they did a great job and I
didn't think it was worth three doing
what they did yes so when you create
your own extension you can publish it to
any NPM repo you want so if you have
your own internal NPM artifactory you
can just publish it to that and anybody
within that has access to that can do it
or if you want to you can actually just
run it locally you have all the code
locally and you just install it locally
and it's not published anywhere so just
like how we just did the button right
now that was all locally it was never
published
what
that answer yes cool this is my team
leads yes
oh let's see I don't believe so
you sort of have to migrate
a couple of other labs like all types
we deployed but most of the very the
most user ones we have already seen
people like alte migrating lab although
so and it is pretty straightforward to
migrate your own extensions this button
demo I had my first time doing a button
demo it was it was a notebook button so
we had a button we just moved it over
any other questions or we could call it
early and everybody can get coffee okay
if anybody wanted to take a picture of
that link just in case it's hard to find
it I'm gonna leave this yeah that's my
last slide so I'll leave this up for a
bit so people can take a picture
it's IBM voxcom /v / AJ Bozarth @ - PI
data 19 nice easy ish to remember URL
yeah so if that's it
thank you for joining I hope I helped
somebody thank you so much
[Applause]